hello everyone and welcome to a
brilliant and very short game a lot of
you have requested it's from the tata
still challengers edition and it's um uh
daniel darda grandmaster from belgium
against paulina chavalova international
master and woman grandmaster from russia
it's a really cool game so uh let's dive
straight into it uh that with the white
pieces opens with c4 uh we have e6
knight to c3 d5 so we started off with
an english with the ashen core defense
but we transpose into the queen's gamba
decline darda goes for d4
c5 going for the tarash defense and now
c captures uh on d5 and it's it's the
same position that uh happened yesterday
in the um
carlson uh shankland game uh sorry in
shanklin carlson game only uh here we
have e captures on d5 whereas carlson
went c captures on d4 he tried to uh
surprise shankland uh but chankland
handled it very well so here we have the
standard e captures on d5 this is the
most common reply knight to f3 knight to
f6 and now bishop to g5 so this is all
very very standard stuff uh bishop to e6
and now e3 preparing to develop our
light square bishop and here just c4 so
in the olden days this would be
characterized as a very anti-positional
idea but nowadays with the advancement
of modern engines there is no such thing
as as being anti-positional so here
knight the e5 always an excellent square
for the knight and uh again the position
has been reached before no moves are
some like queen to queen to b6 uh even
magnus played in this position he played
bishop to e7 against raus lavoitase in
the 2019 world blitz championship he won
that game but here we have queen all the
way to a5 and it is now already as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game uh the idea being now uh getting
the queen away from the spin and now
maybe knight to e4 is an idea putting
pressure on the knight and the bishop of
course the knight here is pin so you're
kind of fighting um even more for the e4
square
and it's white to move so what do you
play here that white of course captures
on f6 you do not want to allow this
knight to e4 idea g captures and now
knight back to f3 so black uh has some
very nice development here but he also
has a double f pawn which shouldn't be a
problem if he for example or rather she
goes knight to c6 castle's queen side
and then maybe uses the g file for the
attack so anything can happen here it
all depends on what uh how white
approaches this position so knight to c6
and now g3 preparing to fianchetto the
light square bishop
and now uh uh paulina plays bishop to f5
and this um again uh it's very hard to
characterize a move as uh
as you know
a principle breaking move uh but this
this piece has already moved so you
should definitely move your other pieces
but of course these are very strong
players of course they know all of this
and like i said with the advancement of
modern engines you always look for that
idea outside the box maybe another
principle can be broken but here maybe
just the standard developing bishop to
b4 we put pressure on the knight white
has to defend the knight and then we
castle queen side and we continue uh
play with the white king still being in
the center of the board but instead
after bishop to g3 we have bishop to f5
now controlling some very very important
squares here
with ideas of bishop to b4 next so we
have a3 now stopping this bishop to b4
idea and only now paulina castles
and now knight to h4 taking
advantage of the bishop on f5 being
undefended and now if you go to g6 then
we just trade it captures captures and
we continue development bishop to g2 and
the white will be more than okay here
the queen is stranded on the queen side
and well white will at some point play
b3 open up the queen side and start an
attack against the black king so here we
have bishop back to e6 returning to the
square from
where it came from and bishop to g2 we
have bishop to e7 continuing development
preparing f5 to again put pressure on
this knight uh castles by daniel and now
f5 uh with the ideas of trapping uh
capturing the knight so knight back to
f3 and now a nice prophylactic king to
b8 as the c file might open up so you
want your king on v8 or maybe even on a8
and now what's the move that we always
discuss and that you always have to
consider when playing
white that is of course pawn to b4 this
is exactly what daniel plays and now the
question is can you capture this alpha
song now the problem is if you capture
white happily captures will bring the
rook over to b1 and will have incredible
pressure along the b file so paulina
just goes back queen to c7 and now rook
to b1 now you are ready to start pushing
those pawns queen is coming maybe to a4
knight to b5 and there will be a lot of
pressure towards that black king and now
uh again it's hard to hard to find the
move for black if h5 we're just gonna
play h4 so of course we're not gonna
allow black to create some attacking
chances so polina plays another
prophylactic move a king to a8 but now
uh queen to a4 and already you're seeing
um a lot of problems here for black this
knight is coming to b5 there's no way
for you to stop this if you play a6
we're still gonna break through we're
just gonna play b5 as the rook is very
nicely placed on b1 so a6 is just
basically giving uh uh white a target so
you should play me something like queen
to b6 but even this
will not be easy to hold however in the
game paulina played knight to b8 and
this is now uh just completely
completely winning for white knight to
b5 was played attacking the queen and
threatening checkmate so there seems to
be only one move that prevents checkmate
and there it is queen to b6 but even
this is uh insufficient to hold the game
uh feel free to pause the video here and
find this incredible winning move while
i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the king is completely boxed in the
night now cuts off the king from
escaping anywhere and that means that we
are definitely looking for a nice modded
mate here here daniel played queen
captures on a7 and there is nothing more
to be done here the only move is queen
captures on a7 this was played and now
comes knight to c7 checkmate and what a
game only 22 moves such a
such a splendid attacking game and
i i found it very interesting that even
though uh like i said in in modern times
we can consider many anti-positional
ideas because our you know uh uh
synthetic overlords uh said that it's
okay but uh here uh maybe it was a a a
bit too much and just here for example
starting with bishop to f5 gave white a
couple of very important tempi
to mount this attack but maybe okay
maybe you could still hold it with
perfect play but uh after that uh
after that um uh queen to c7 uh and
everything here just uh
knight the b8 there is no more holding
this so really a fine idea a fine
checkmate and well really hope you guys
enjoyed this and i know there are a lot
of cool games being played in the
challengers edition we are mostly
covering the masters but if you have
your own favorite we are definitely
going to cover them now today is the
rest today so we have uh time to check
up on some other games and i know that
you guys have been requesting
for me to check out some of um arjun
eric aces games uh and we will check
them out but uh probably uh well
during a second rest day or maybe after
the masters is over we're gonna check
out more than one game maybe even uh
consider maybe i'll consider even
covering his entire event as he's just
having a spectacular event uh
i'm pretty sure that he's going to win
it this one and that we can expect him
next year in the in the master
edition so brilliant attacking him by
darda i've been told this is his second
uh crushing game in 22 moves so he's
having a very nice tournament here i
think he uh i could check uh give me
just a second i think i don't know uh
how many how oh okay uh okay so he got
uh
uh two two wins so far and three losses
yeah uh one of them too today easy as he
is just crushing this tournament uh one
to evolve in and one to arena to mobive
uh but nice nice uh nice victory uh
nevertheless uh so
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
that thank you for suggesting such a
wonderful gym i would like to thank
david kimura thomas earl trevor fortado
souza uh gwen cook khan and william rose
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh with the coverage of this
wonderful event and the other one uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day